one of the things that is important to
prevent because once the cat is out of
the bag it's very difficult to get it
back in
is the rewriting of history anytime that
we can and when it comes to the last
couple of years the pandemic the trump
administration etc
we've been covering it all closely with
you with no interruption and so it gives
us sort of this
perspective where we can remember what
things were like last year or two years
ago
when the right tries to rewrite history
for political advantage or whatever the
case may be now this is a
politically biased show in the sense
that this might come as a shock to some
of you which is a problem but this is
not a news reporting show this is a news
commentary and analysis show i'm on the
left i'm a progressive that's my
perspective
but one of the things that i always try
to do
or try not to do depending on your
perspective is
i don't want to toss the political
football back and forth
on issues
that are not really worthy of that and
you know that on debt and deficit i
don't play into the debt and deficit
games that both republicans and
democrats play but republicans play it
more for sure because they're the ones
who claim to be the party of uh fiscal
responsibility as they define it uh on
gas prices for example i've told you
guys when it was bush that was president
when it was obama when it was trump now
under joe biden the american president
has very little influence over gas
prices so i don't use gas prices as
something to praise
or
beat down
a president i these games are boring to
me we're beyond them and now the issue
of supply chain and shortages is taking
exactly the same tone and color
um it's joe biden's fault if as the
other day when i went to the grocery
store i couldn't get my granny smith
apples and i tweeted about it and got
into a funny exchange with sam cedar
about it but i'm not blaming joe biden
for that much like i didn't blame donald
trump for the shortage as we saw earlier
in the pandemic but the right wants to
play the games and tom not only is the
right now blaming joe biden for
everything that's going on and saying
well we have shortages because secretary
of transportation pete but edge edge was
on paternity leave
it even led to sort of homophobic stuff
about oh he's learning to breastfeed and
stuff like this um
and now
republican senator tom cotton went on
laura ingram's show last night and said
we didn't have shortages under donald
trump during the first year of the
pandemic what
this is beyond parody take a listen to
this
or in the morning you know we've had
this pandemic for two years laura i
don't remember inflation or supply chain
shortages or labor shortages that we've
seen this year in the first year of the
pandemic what changed joe biden and the
democrats took power in january can you
imagine
can you imagine so
labor shortages well that's very very
silly
during
the vast majority of trump's
uh uh presidency during the pandemic
things were shut down there were too
many workers in the sense that a ton of
businesses were closed
entertainment venues
movie theaters sporting events
many restaurants when it came to
in-house dining rather than just take
out
the situation was completely different
that's why there weren't so-called labor
shortages under trump now whether
they're even really shortages now it i i
think that that's actually the wrong
term for them but that's very silly but
he's saying there weren't supply chain
issues do you guys remember toilet paper
under donald trump you couldn't find
toilet paper
when it came back in stock there were
limits no one package per person you
can't get two packages of toilet paper
under trump was i blaming trump for that
of course not it had nothing to do with
trump there were no n95 masks available
there were no kn 95 masks available
people were desperate to get those
surgical masks you couldn't get hand
sanitizer couldn't find sanitizing wipes
on amazon your local cvs couldn't find
it the lysol and other sprays i wanted
to get rubbing alcohol sold out
everywhere i ended up ordering a two
pack from like target online or
something like that there were no canned
foods you'd go to the grocery store not
only was the grocery store
packed
with lines waiting outside you couldn't
find canned soup you couldn't find black
beans you couldn't find pinto beans you
couldn't find kidney beans you couldn't
find cannellini beans you couldn't find
refried beans you couldn't find spicy
refried beans you couldn't find fava
beans
okay i could go on i'm big on beans as
you can tell um the dry pasta section
empty no spaghetti no ziti no penne no
gnocchi no pepper deli no rotini
linguini angel hair cavatapi tagliatelli
fusilli macaroni farfale conchiglier
you couldn't find lasagna noodles guys
lasagna noodles i was trying to make
lasagna couldn't find them
costco was limiting how much meat you
could buy
meat was being rationed folks whole
foods said you only
one of each kind of frozen fruit or
vegetable i wanted two packages of
frozen mango i was only allowed to buy
one
there was no flour and sugar people were
baking like crazy due to boredom
couldn't uh ammunition was sold out
everywhere remember that
and tom cotton doesn't remember anything
like this
before
this year
under joe biden
what
but the important thing is
no one was blaming trump for that back
then even people on the left weren't
saying it's trump's fault that there's
no pit toilet paper because it would be
idiotic just like the other day at the
grocery store i wanted my beloved granny
smith apples and they were sold out
thanksgiving probably had something to
do with it the green apple very very
strong for apple pie
let's put that aside it's not just but
joe biden's fault
if anything it's thanksgiving's fault
okay
these guys have to give it up i mean
it's we it's on us not to allow them to
get away with this it was not trump's
fault but there were shortages under
trump
and it is not joe biden's fault that now
you know i wanted to get quiche crusts
the other day and they were sold out i'm
not blaming pete but judges uh premature
twins that he has adopted that it's just
it just has nothing to do with that it's
very silly let's not allow them to
rewrite history
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't be the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep the sofa it comes
with a forever warranty and you'll get
20 off when you go to all form.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video